[Música]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy herminia Fernández
gramators Es la ciudad más importante de
la provincia de donest que todavía
permanece bajo control ucraniano como en
el resto del donbad sus habitantes
sienten que la guerra está cada vez más
cerca y se ha hecho evidente Desde que
la batalla por la población de bakmuk a
55 kilómetros se intensificó a finales
de noviembre desde entonces ha sufrido
ataques sistemáticamente muchos de sus
habitantes esperan que la contraofensiva
les regrese la tranquilidad al tiempo
que las autoridades tienen todo
preparado por si el frente de batalla se
acerca aún más Catalina Gómez ángel con
los detalles
ya limpiamos esas calles estaban
cubiertas con piedras bien hace parte de
un batallón de empleados municipales que
se moviliza cada vez que kramators es
alcanzada por los misiles y la
artillería rusa el frente de batalla se
acerca cada vez más y más desde bajo
mundo nos da mucho miedo todo lo que
pasa nos da mucho miedo
Desde que la lucha por la vecina Back se
intensificó durante el invierno las
ciudades atacadas al menos tres veces a
la semana en esta ocasión Los rusos
lanzaron una decena de misiles durante
la madrugada dos de ellos cayeron en el
patio de este colegio en el centro de la
ciudad considerada el eje administrativo
y militar de la provincia de dones en
control de Ucrania ataques como Estos no
son
una sexual
son más frecuentes Y es que nos dicen
los habitantes que tienen miedo que en
la medida que el frente de batalla se
acerque y la contraofensiva ucraniana se
intensifica o empiece de una vez estos
ataques se van a hacer mayores
obligatorio si el frente de batalla se
acerca más vamos a comenzar la
evacuación obligatoria de la gente pero
espero que nuestros militares sostengan
el frente de batalla donde se encuentra
actualmente
miles de habitantes huyeron de la ciudad
después de que comenzó la invasión a
gran escala pero con el paso del tiempo
han regresado al menos 25.000 personas
viven aquí a pesar del peligro un
ejemplo es este cohete que cayó en medio
de la noche frente a una vivienda en un
barrio Residencial esta vez Tuvieron
suerte y no explotó no lo sentimos lo
encontramos tirado siempre oímos
silbidos en la noche pasan por encima
de vuelta al colegio Luzmila se ha unido
a un grupo de profesores y alumnos que
intentan limpiar los escombros confiesa
que siente mucho miedo cada vez que hay
un ataque teme que alguien pueda morir
esperamos Que la contraofensiva empiece
que nuestros hombres los expulsen y sus
cohetes no puedan alcanzar clamatorios
expectativa por lo que pueda pasar en
las próximas semanas es grande muchos
creen que Su futuro dependerá del rumbo
que toma la guerra una vez que haya
empezado la contraofensiva
el miércoles 13 de mayo se celebró el
Día Mundial de la libertad de prensa y
Centroamérica es una de las regiones más
peligrosas para ejercer el periodismo
nuestros reporteros se acercaron a los
casos de Nicaragua y El Salvador porque
sus periodistas han encontrado refugio
en Costa Rica más en el siguiente
reportaje de Elmer Rivas Vladimir
Chamorro y Muñoz
es Costa Rica pero también Nicaragua
especialmente para los medios de
comunicación
185 periodistas nicaragüenses han salido
al exilio desde 2018 el caso más
paradigmático es el del diario La prensa
El más antiguo del país con 97 años de
existencia en julio de 2022 toda la
redacción se exilió en Costa Rica Fabián
Medina es su editor un periodista igual
a un arco periodismo y narcotráfico o
algo así un delito grave que se
considera grave
ejercer el periodismo en Nicaragua y se
y se percibe como tal
les confiscaron sus instalaciones y
allanaron sus casas es el caso del
fotorreportero Óscar Navarrete después
de cubrir la expulsión de Nicaragua de
las monjas misioneras de la Caridad se
me llevaron equipos de la prensa y
equipos míos personales entre ellos
computadoras tablet laptop cámara
fotográficas lentes y yo vine acá a este
país con un iPhone 7 y eso no me detuvo
de seguir haciendo periodismo gráfico la
prensa no ha sido el único medio
perseguido en Nicaragua 22 periodistas
han perdido la nacionalidad como Lucía
pinedaubau que además llegó a estar
presa cerca de seis meses antes de salir
a Costa Rica su medio 100% noticias fue
confiscado también su casa hemos sido
encarcelado hemos sido robados nuestros
medios de comunicación nos han robado la
nacionalidad nos han despojado de
nuestros pasaportes
nos han perseguido incluso
persecución contra la prensa se filtra
por las fronteras centroamericanas como
en El Salvador de nayib bukele El Faro
uno de los referentes en investigación
de América Latina ha decidido mover su
operación administrativa y legal también
a Costa Rica Sergio arauz es uno de sus
directivos también forma parte de la
asociación de periodistas del Salvador
estamos en un momento muy crítico
desde hace algunos años Creo yo que el
bucalismo ha montado un escenario
dispuesto para
restringir la labor de los periodistas y
de los medios Honduras y Guatemala
tampoco escapan de la persecución contra
la prensa convirtiendo a Centroamérica
en una zona roja para aquellos que se
atreven a fiscalizar al poder en Chile
las autoridades hacen su mayor esfuerzo
por recuperar la vida la economía los
negocios y la actividad de las llamadas
Zona cero de las protestas ocurridas
entre 2019 y 2020 durante meses esta
área estuvo convertida en un campo de
enfrentamiento entre policías y
manifestantes ahora el espacio vuelve a
ser retomado por negocios y habitantes y
trata de volver poco a poco a la
normalidad Patricia Luna nos cuenta más
Olga rojas es vecina desde hace más de
40 años de Plaza Italia el centro de las
manifestaciones del estallido Social
chileno en 2019 vivió de cerca como su
comunidad se convirtió en un campo de
batalla las cicatrices aún son visibles
en los muros las calles e incluso las
veredas ahora el barrio vuelve poco a
poco a la normalidad se plantan flores
limpian fachadas los departamentos se
vuelven a alquilar Olga está contenta
por la recuperación del lugar no podía
prender la luz no podía ir a trabajar no
podía salir a comprar
angustiante muy angustiante y me
evacuaban tres veces al día los bomberos
porque siempre había fuego abajo a su
casa llegaron incluso disparos en la
ventana
ese tiempo quedó atrás también para
aquellos que tienen negocios en la zona
y que sufrieron pérdidas estimadas en
más de 130 millones de dólares en el
sector según el último catastro en esta
Vereda muy cercana donde se registraban
los enfrentamientos solo tres de 17
negocios permanecen abiertos Carlos Siri
administra uno la antigua fuente uno de
los clásicos del barrio antes siempre
rebosante de gente
he ido recuperando pero nosotros estamos
en términos reales parados en una venta
que sería como el 60% de lo que
vendíamos o sea todavía falta mucho para
alcanzar los niveles quizás que teníamos
las autoridades del gobierno regional
han previsto 100 actividades culturales
para tratar de devolver la vida al
barrio entre ellas Esta obra de teatro
que Valeria una enfermera acude a ver
con toda su familia volver a Santiago
nuevamente y sentirse seguro la verdad
que es un tema que aún nos cuesta pero
creo que esta iniciativa nos va a
entregar eso esta seguridad es poder
volver nuevamente a nuestras calles a
nuestra ciudad tienen actividades
culturales para cicatrizar heridas
sociales y retomar poco a poco una parte
de la ciudad y un espacio simbólico
cargado todavía de mucha emocionalidad
El Vaticano cuenta con un ejército
creado el 21 de enero de 1506 por el
papa Julio II quien pidió la
confederación helvética los mejores
guardias con fama de feroces guerreros
para su custodia personal así fue creada
la famosa Guardia Suiza pontificia un
cuerpo de élite al servicio de los papas
de la Iglesia Católica entre las
funciones de este cuerpo militar están
las de proteger al sumo pontífice
acompañarlo en sus viajes vigilar los
accesos al Estado de la ciudad del
Vaticano y resguardar a los Cardenales
durante el cónclave que eligen a un
nuevo papa funciones que perduran desde
hace cinco siglos el reportaje es de
Natalia Mendoza
a donde quiera que va el papa ahí están
junto a él son los guardias suizos
custodios del sumo pontífice vestidos en
civil o con sus pintorescos uniformes
garantizan la seguridad del jefe de la
Iglesia Católica en cualquier situación
no es fácil ser guardaespaldas del Papa
Francisco es alguien muy sociable le
gusta el contacto con la gente las
multitudes hacemos preparación mental y
psicológica observamos los
comportamientos de la gente para
anticipar las potenciales situaciones de
peligro
esta tarde en el cuartel de los guardias
suizos situado en el corazón del
Vaticano un grupo de jóvenes soldados se
prepara para el entrenamiento Danilo
tiene 22 años y es uno de los 124
miembros del ejército más pequeño del
mundo
antes del entrenamiento tenemos que
pulir bien las corazas quitarles todas
las manchas de grasa que se van
impregnando en el Metal
terminada la preparación inicia el
entrenamiento
la guardia Suiza pontificia nació en
1506 cuando el papa Julio II pidió a
Suiza soldados para su protección y
formó una compañía de 150 hombres
hoy en día este ejército sigue atrayendo
a jóvenes reclutas como Álex uno de los
23 nuevos soldados que han Jurado
fidelidad al papa este año
decidí ingresar en la guardia Suiza no
solo porque es una experiencia muy
interesante a nivel profesional en el
sector de la seguridad pero también
porque lo veo como una ocasión de
profundizar mi fe
para entrar en ese ejército Hay que ser
ciudadano suizo católico practicante
soltero tener entre 19 y 30 años una
reputación impecable y mucho empeño y
pues se necesita voluntad y mucha
tenacidad porque al inicio no es nada
fácil
los reclutas se comprometen a prestar
servicio por al menos 26 meses
protegiendo al papa y perpetuando la
tradición del ejército más antiguo del
mundo
hasta que corresponsales de la semana
nuestro agradecimiento hoy es a la
librería francesa tiempos futuros siga
con más información por Francia 24 y
France 24.com
[Aplausos]